You were, or you worked in a bunch of companies, uh,
you let a lot of amazing teams. Um,
I don't ha I'm not sure if you've ever been like in the early stages of a
startup, but do you have advice for,
uh, somebody that wants to, uh,
do a startup or build a company like build a strong team of engineers that are
passionate and just want to, um, solve a big problem? Like,
is there a more specifically on that point?
Well, you have to be really good at stuff.
If you're going to lead and build a team,
you better be really interested in how people work and think.
PayPal or the solution to the problem. So there's two things, right?
One is how people work and the other is.
That's actually, there's, there's quite a few successful startups.
So it's pretty clear. The founders don't know anything about people.
Like the idea was so powerful, that approach for a problem.
But I suspect somewhere early, they hired some people who understood people,
cause people really need a lot of care and feeding, collaborate,
and work together and feel engaged and work hard, you know, like startup.
So it was all about producing other people.
Like you're nimble because you don't have any legacy. You don't have, you know,
a bunch of people who are depressed about life, you know, just showing up know.
So startups have a lot of advantages that way.
Do you like the Steve jobs talked about this idea of a players and B
players? I don't know if you know this formulation.
Now, um, that,
that organizations that get taken over by P B player leaders
often really underperformed.
There are so few players that said in big organizations,
there's so much work to do. Like,
and there's so many people are happy to do what, you know,
like the leadership or the big idea.
People can see it consider menial jobs and you know, you need a place for them,
but you need an organization that both values and rewards them,
but doesn't let them take over the leadership of it.
Got it. But, so, so you need to have an organization that's resistant to that,
but in the early days, the notion with,
with Steve was that like one B player in a room of a players will
be like destructive to the whole.
I've seen that happen. I don't know if it's like always true. Like,
you know, you, you run into people who are clearly B players,
but they think they're very players.
And so they have a loud voice at the table and they make lots of demands for
that. But there's other people that are like, I know who I am.
I just want to work with cool people on cool and just told me what to do and
I'll go get it done. You know? So you have to, again,
this is like people skills, like what kind of person has it? You know,
I've met some really great people.
I love working with you that weren't the biggest ID people,
their most productive ever, but they show up, they get it done. You know, they,
they create connection and community that people value.
It's pretty diverse. So I don't think there's a recipe for that.